[Music]
in asking for a favor news of a bug the
stick is what I gave up what's that song
I don't know there's a cold favor no I'm
just gonna guess you guys know the song
I'm talking about all right I don't know
holy do that I know these guys right
here they absolutely do yes they do
write it in the comments I know you know
look we don't know please just write out
we don't know Molly and cheesecake oh
that's the one with the strawberries but
they put it directly into your hands so
there's no plates in Jamal Sam what you
don't need plates no color Somalia is a
utopian [ __ ] country yeah you don't
need plates you wouldn't eat you gotta
eat Oh Mike you got mistake that's it
yeah and it's baked in the like that's
what the whole pie crust is for the pie
crust is to hold it like a pizza sounds
delicious all foods in Joe Maddalena
have some sort of a plating as a built
into them you eat the spoon that it
comes with Oh
nothing goes to waste it's like those
sourdough clam chowder bowls yeah
everything is used that's good you're
selling me man salty get this started I
think we gonna be the dough aliens chef
you know it I'm so [ __ ] hungry right
now is that look on your face when you
go like that he's a user
I'm hungry face yeah okay yeah if we
don't have JK anymore you'll never be
hungry ever again because you'll be the
official cook nice that's right a man
pulls on Facebook up hey okay a man a
man post to the Facebook yet I just slip
sinister sorry Mandy hosted a Facebook
ad offering everything he owns to the
person who kills him well I would love
to kill him a generous bounty I'm sure I
would love it I don't understand why
it's so bad to kill someone if they ask
you to do it you got that all you had
was a total issue in a [ __ ] 25 cent
eye
I pictured the biggest Buccaneer I would
be
yeah that's no deal that's no deal I
couldn't do it for that not cheap that's
too cheap right not even worth it and
what if he gets garbage just pure
garbage I would have to make sure that
that somehow Nicky would never have to
do anything again forever I love in your
scenario you always think of Nicky I
completely forgot mine you are a good
good man and you're making it illegal
I'm just living up to my bond dude
that's it it's just this is the word of
the word I gave because this is legal
than my mouth he said I will murder an
Tabata for you Nicky that's true but you
wrote dreading their wedding violet the
night before
thanks a lot Bart no don't tell Bart's
no secrets it was a secret if the lesson
you've learned no actually is no they
tried they're trying to bust me on this
big but really the what was it like I
document was modified the night before I
got married that does not mean that I
wrote the whole thing how did you modify
it or like what put some finishing
touches on it real quick and I had to
send it to my best man who's you can't
tell these [ __ ] secrets at all no no
he did tell me I discovered it I'm just
gonna put one in the movie document and
they saw my wedding vows document well
I'll tell ya 30 seconds that's the
working towels or tomb the JK movie she
came up how many pages 74 before 4:00
now 74 page first shaft could be 80
could be 80 could be way more we'll see
what is it about 30 seconds guess what
it is
o virgin not becoming a virgin anymore
no no no how long I last in bed that's
right it's actually how long we all ask
them together
really
he's these a good 30 on his own dizzy
yeah 30 seconds hell yeah especially I
go slow that's seven times all right I
think my fingers don't still stimulator
yeah
can't tell which ones which yeah that's
great good I can't say I'm really good
at fingering yeah that's a big [ __ ] no
I'm good at finger that's what I was
thinking for a second to uh sigh how big
is Nicky's [ __ ] by God
hey thanks to me it's pretty big friend
for life I can't stretch our chest like
that you're not trying you don't even I
don't want to get two hands you got a
dick you can figure it's like that game
when you play with your friends like
this preparing you for the worst oh that
made my spine tingle a little bit in a
good way what's this about try to get
other people to kill them
oh sorry for my stress in business at
home I'm not trying to [ __ ] no burlap
sack right okay what is it itchy though
cuz it's so bigger loose but why is it
hanging though it's a big burlap sack
you rip it apart you just stretch it out
like a bag of onions right why is it
what does she not shave and it's prickly
and wise to see through oh oh this has
nothing to do with anything but for some
reason why I want to segue to this did
you know people get anal piercings wait
how do you pierce it like a bellybutton
it doesn't close it's pierced with next
to the butt hole and the the Gooch area
yeah that should freak me the [ __ ] out
so when you do baby inside you get this
because Vanessa made a joke she was like
blah blah something ain't no peers no
that doesn't exist she go are you sure
and I was like I don't remember how that
joke came about I was like yeah I'm
pretty sure she was Google it right now
and I was wrong it does exist
Oh
now there's gonna be a lot of people
googling that [ __ ] right now yeah you'll
see it it's there you know what I'm
picturing so I'm picturing this when you
do it Dookie right the anal piercing
scrapes a design all across the Duke you
when it comes out no wait so then with
you with your example then your Dookie
is getting on your ball sack I don't
think that's what happens
maybe it's like it's like a piercing
that scrapes it and then it makes a
design that she's woman swaying to him
what happens to his boss that when we do
he she doesn't know [ __ ] about it yo yo
hey hey hey we got it here
a woman go ahead you explain us to how
explaining I just said admit that logic
I said this is what it sounds like when
doves cry I just like it when women get
angry and they have to every word it
annoys me yeah it looks like a feel
that's a clap and a half all right so
back to this story sorry this is sad
sorry sorry sorry
so this is what was posted on a Facebook
group called Gold Coast buy sell and
swap with easy rules that's in Australia
Gold Coast yeah so this takes place so
his location is Quinlan Australian he
posted I will pay someone with
everything I own for one favor anyone
interested and then it says that sounds
like that what he's the payment what's
he got
it's $300 plus TV Xbox one 360
Playstation that's a lot of games about
100 games 60 DVDs two laptops two
Morris's which i think is mattresses all
that if one person grants my request
like a kid this office possessions
actually looks like everything you have
in one room he could keep the DVDs oh it
makes it even more scientific but it's
part of team 1617 it's like an older guy
who just couldn't get it together yeah I
will say when I was about 23
that's about all I own but you probably
have a cartoon
right yeah I had a cartoon he's not I
had a [ __ ] beer car do is grow never
feeling suicidal 23 now I was like 13 oh
really
I was sad do you remember what it was
about or was it about everything no I
was just like everything my parents
didn't let me go to school or so or like
they forced me to go to school because I
come so like if I get a [ __ ] up
haircut they'll still make me go to
school and I'm like I'm gonna kill
myself
I'm so sad that's all it took I'm sure
somebody's gonna relate to you I was
like I can't face my classmates I [ __ ]
up my fame man never thought about
killing myself no that's awesome I never
ever once in my life I could not about
killing myself yeah when I was like
eight or nine really young for that [ __ ]
huh my parents beat my ass every single
day and I got in trouble I got my ass
beat twice that was probably the real
reason why I wanted to myself but it
came out with a haircut problem yeah
it's never the route we're always
complaining about stupid [ __ ] like I
always thought about killing other
people but I never thought about myself
I like myself - I thought of both - like
I was like man like I'm - I don't have
enough courage to do it myself so like I
wish there was a way I remember thinking
this I wish it was away like I could
somehow tell someone to do it for me
without me knowing it's gonna happen
oh all you gotta do is just start [ __ ]
walking in a blood day bruh hood and
we're all blue you good is that right
yeah that's true
instantly probably yep yeah that's so
sad I used to think grip walking was
just so funny-looking right let that one
walk right were you going it's very
difficult trying to hold your feet right
yeah everyone else would I tried
multiple times it did not work out the
way I wanted to I'm I am my own head a
ton of the knees at [ __ ] walk and how do
you do that when you're like 60 very
hard knees you do it the og way what how
slippers oh my batter I need to see a
tutorial because I think I did it the
wrong way let's get back here so he
ends up responding to his own post he
says not a joke the favor is simple no
way it's not simple he said like
everyone's like what's the request kill
me oh my god it's not that easy bro yeah
and then people are saying how come you
can't do it if it's so easy huh right
that's what I would have said reasonable
simple yeah I gotta [ __ ] Jail prolly
you know what's even worse when I hear
the phrase kill me I just think of dr.
Dow remember that Delta I know I should
have make jokes about it but I do
consistently
whenever I see a carton I just hold on
to it I go to kill me some people are
just he didn't kill himself right we're
okay he wants other people to feel
better about what we're talking about
it's not funny if you committed suicide
yeah right now it seems like he's fine
yes the police didn't have a statement
saying that they want to go visit a man
that seems to be this man yes and that
he received medical attention okay and
that's all I can comment point is either
life that's good did he trade the Xbox
and the PlayStation and all and stuff
for a medical attention it gives the
police officers haha
they also have the world's deadliest
bugs and spiders in the whole world so
they better have that [ __ ] I will say
that I concur
no what the [ __ ] look at your hair I
don't know well he concurs okay I concur
yeah the hands are just responding
there's just a lot of people giving him
support saying like you know if you want
and you want to talk to him here or
that's dope I'm glad those people are
around because I would be the one that
would read it I begged a Matz us well
good luck to this guy and I would just
think of sending good vibes and then I
just have to go about my day Facebook
helps with that too by the way
because your names like attached to it I
feel like a lot of times it gets
anonymous and people that just kill
yourself you [ __ ] or whatever you know
yeah they keep you accountable yeah yeah
they need to do for all the other
platforms or yeah all of them oh you
have to put you know what you know on
Yelp to
if you do have a Yelp business page your
profile and
to be a picture of your face Oh can't be
like a distant photo or anything has to
be of your face or you can't upload it
and you can't make modifications to your
Yelp business office yeah so there's
accountability I love it so awesome I
like it and I don't like it because I
like being people being able to post
their true thoughts without having to
worry about their identity being exposed
I do dig that I think that's important
because there could certain countries
like like China oh yeah so start at the
toughy
[Music]